Jason is in Philadelphia to start off
this hour hi Jason how are you hi Dave
I'm doing well how about yourself
better than I deserve what's up
excellent thanks for taking my call
so I've done and my wife's have done a
couple stupid things here and just
trying to find out where we should get
started and and kind of right the ship
so turning 40 next year and we booked a
trip to the Caribbean to celebrate then
we realized how we're going to pay for
it and thought about that you know and
as an eff result and finally got our
heads out of the sand and kind of did an
assessment of where we're at and just
kind of eye-opening
we just went went through and collected
some debts and made some stupid
decisions and now we're kind of here we
are
and trying to find out where we should
start and improve the situation here
we've got four kids and I just live in
the suburb but why is here I'm probably
doing a lot of stupid stuff so I want to
get your opinion okay so you cancelled
the trip to the Caribbean did you no I
have not
why you know I didn't even occur to me I
don't know if we'd get penalized or lose
money cuz you already put about half of
it down okay well I guess you need to
find that out
okay yeah cuz apparently you're broke
right yeah if we've um yeah we're about
sixty-five thousand in debt yeah well
thank you doing the house I don't think
you go to a Caribbean trip when you're
65 km dude that's just irresponsible
right so um now what kind of debt is
this so we've got just a little bit of
school loan two cars again here's the
stupidity two new cars from 2013-2014
what do you own them got thirteen on one
and fifteen on another okay we took out
brace yourself a 401k loan and that's 31
Belvin
I'm just over 600 on a school loan
that's going to be over in January for
15 years it's located and just credit
card debt that we pay off every month
religiously how old are you guys
39 and my wife is 37 go now what's your
household income we're doing pretty
pretty well there so we we're doing
about 220 pre-tax okay so why are you
this broke that's a great question
just spending kind of living living
without thinking about the future both
of our mom's past at a young age and
playing psychologists I think we do a
little bit of live while you're young
and not push it off to the end and you
know they did they saved and never got
to travel and never got to do things
that they planned for and we fell into
that trap and and what I'm realizing now
you know hey we have these four kids
that depend on us and we can't live like
this hmm well here's a good news okay
when's the trip scheduled for it in
February pretty quick okay correct well
then the first step you did was you
assess the amount of debt that you've
got the same thing you need to do is
start doing a written budget jump on
every dollar calm and start using that
online tool it's free to develop a
budget you can develop a budget with
your spouse sitting there in about ten
minutes
okay and that's going to show you this
huge amount of money that's unaccounted
for okay I mean you're making great
money and really you should be able to
clean this up very very quickly maybe
you don't have to cancel the trip but if
I'm you I'm just going to go hey I work
too hard and I make too much money to be
broke right and that's different than
Yolo even I mean that's different than
you know that's different than just love
your life you know you just just live in
life for today that that's just being
your responsible you make so much money
there's just waste in here it's like
like your Congress or something so I
mean you know it's just there's a lot of
wonderful things you can do here yes I
mean what is your house payment it is I
think 14 so you could clean up to 65,000
in no time
I mean you by summer you ought to be
debt-free that would be fantastic yeah
but I mean you're not going to have much
of a life between now and then but yeah
I'm what I would do is I would set
myself a very strenuous debt reduction
goal and if I if I can hit that then I
would stay on the trip okay the only
reason I would do that's because you're
making this kind of money if you told me
you're making 100 I'm canceling the trip
sure but you've got such a you you not
got that big a hole you're in and you
have a huge shovel so it's just kind of
kind of it's mathematically ludicrous
you know well it's great it's great to
hear it feels like we're kind of trapped
with you know holidays coming up and
stuff you know the the you know we want
to be good role models for the kids if
you put your income at the top of the
page if you just did a yellow pad and
took out your house payment and your car
payments and your food there's so much
money left I mean there's so much money
left right you guys have just been
sloppy yeah just sloppy I mean it's more
than just living life for today you've
been sloppy and that's the bad news the
good news is is you can change it today
you can just go okay we're going to
write this down I mean let's pretend I
hired you for $200,000 to manage you're
a different family that had your
situation you're not dumb people don't
people don't make this kind of money
mm-hmm I mean you're smart people you're
just doing dumb stuff yep and so I mean
if you just if you were emotionally
detached from this and you put 225
thousand at the top of the page - you
know you're your living expenses
- sixty-five thousand - a Caribbean trip
that's a 12-month budget you're done you
know mm-hmm Yatta will do that it's just
you know it's just there's so many
gaping holes in this so yeah get on the
budget form there and you and your wife
say we're going to get committed to
being smarter and you're going to be
able to live and do whatever you want to
do this time next year you're going to
be free to be able to you but you're
just going to do it on purpose from now
on instead of just wandering along like
like you're childish or something you
know you just make what you do for a
living
I'm an IT manager my wife is a project
manager for a bank yeah okay perfect so
in both cases you're managing projects
you sit down in a situation and you
begin with the end in mind right correct
that's all a budget is you have a
225,000 on a project laying here in
front of you and you need to begin with
the end in mind I don't even care what
the end is if you just do it on purpose
you'll start doing smart stuff the dumb
stuff you're doing is just because you
weren't doing anything on purpose
there's no intentionality here you got
it so just make this a project
management issue and that's because
that's how both of your minds work
you'll be able to knock it out in no
time and you're you know your flow chart
you're your product or your project map
is this budget gosh every dollar calm
call me back and tell me how you're
doing or if you need some help this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you